i'm going to show you my answer i'm
going to show you both my answers i'll
show you the algebra and then i will
show you what made someone even think
like why would they do that there are
lots of steps where just like in a
classic triggered any proof that's quite
hard they lay off i'm going to add and
subtract the same thing but why okay so
here's what I'm doing now let's rewind
to all the purse that you've ever needed
to do in the tune extension 14 course
think about geometry proofs think about
induction proofs of which you know this
if you try to do this by induction I was
not a bad idea because like oh preuss
that's the only context I've seen it
appointed crusing before there's a
there's a kind of red flag though that
tells you in dutchess not going to be
very helpful he does anyone go and see
what the red flag is is three variables
that's a problem but it's not like it
doesn't rule you out right so I know a
means here all positive right there a
positive but they all add up to one so
that means they're all fractions of some
kind right so this is going to be a bit
of an issue like inductions primarily
dealing with whole numbers right so even
though it's not ruling us out completely
it sort of indicates to you are there
other ways so female all the proof you
ever had to do one of the key things is
you should always start with what you
know and then try and move towards what
you're supposed to prove okay now you
know precious little in this question in
fact you only know two things you only
know that they're all positive and they
are successively bigger or smaller than
each other and then you know that
there's this relationship is this song
okay so I kind of have to choose one of
those as my starting point or something
else that's what we would call
axiomatically true like I'm the square
of real numbers are always positive or
zero can I use one of these okay but
some light suggests which one of those
would be
good starting point to number 11 number
two that's interesting I've kind of had
one I've heard both and they are good
there are sort of clues in both of them
that would leave us towards saying yeah
this is worthwhile for example what's
this one got money for it that makes it
like oh yeah I'd rather work with this
to get there whatwhat obvious thing is
there so yeah it's a name it's an
inequality thank you right so if I can
just set this I can just sort of twist
and turn this I've already got it in
quality for and then men your substitute
this in somehow okay that's what this
has got going for it what about this
some people said number two you said
this wonder why fantastic so remember
we're still at this point where we're
like I'm a much I'm sort of like firing
off in random directions and I don't
know work and go I've seen the
inequalities over here and then I seen
this one over here okay which one do I
go with now I'm going to go with number
two I think it has a bit more in comment
not only doesn't have this winding
comedy you've just noticed it's a little
bit hidden but it's got a B and C all
together right and it's also a song do
you notice that okay so I'd like to try
and work with this so this is my
starting point okay so if I'm if I'm
tree a plus B plus equals one is my
first line what would be the most
obvious thing I could do to try and get
from here to here and someone asked
Sasori right I think square is a great
idea right because all of those things
are squares nothing over here is a
square so why are we square things I've
got a left-hand side on the right-hand
side let's just try this so i'm going to
write it like this square the left
square the right everything's looking
good
okay so this is fine let's push it this
a little further up a plus B plus C you
can memorize this if you like but I
don't think there's that much point
there's a nice easy way to remember what
this results is but i'm not going to
show it to you yet because it will spoil
my next up my next step um this
expansion a square plus B squared plus
it's worth I think that much is obvious
right because you eventually can
multiply this by itself and this by
itself and despite self right if you
want to think about it in terms of poems
and comms right this is this right so
how many ways are there to choose the
eight twice there's one way right how
many ways are there to choose the beam
twice one way and how many ways are
there a way to choose the sea twice okay
but then when I say oh how many ways are
there to choose an A and a B in any
order because when i write algebra
doesn't matter and the answer is this
too right i could go a and then be or i
can go B and then a right there will
always be too and there's going to be
two of every other combination as well
okay so from that corollary I'm going to
say this is to a b2b see into a sea okay
of course you can just you know machine
the algebra art if you like but i prefer
seen hey there's a leak between algebra
and pam's encantas kind of neat okay so
far so good I've got two things that are
good and a few things that are not so
good okay I've got some a squared b
squared c squared thumbs up I've got a 1
also a thumbs up but then I have two
problems what I
okay yeah I gotta get all this fluff
which seems have nothing to do with the
words all i want and i have an equality
not an inequality okay so i'm on the
right track burner because i know i've
got so many pieces here so i've used one
piece i'll try to push on that a little
bit this guy looks like it must be
important right so how do i use you well
i'm going to use this in one fell swoop
and again you'll ask the question how do
I know how to do this once I show you
the second method you'll become apparent
I'm going to note that these guys can be
transformed I can transform these into
other things and put an inequality in
the place of an equation okay here's how
I'm going to do it I'm going to notice
that which since i'll write it this way
b is less than a right a is the biggest
one biz next they'll see they're all
positive since b is less than a and all
of the numbers are positive right i can
multiply this inequality by any of these
numbers i like right because they were
positive and whatnot with the inequality
or anything like that so for instance i
might multiply through by be do you
agree with that okay oh hey did you see
it right maybe that's all you need but
you see now like you see how I've got to
a bee's there right well these abs are
both going to be bigger than B squared
so I can say this a squared plus B
squared plus c squared right if i
replace that with a B squared well be
Squared's have to be smaller than a beat
so this thing if I just put the rest of
it this thing is not equal to 1 anymore
I replace this piece with something
smaller than that so so it must be
smaller than what the original rival do
you agree maybe I don't need to go any
further right in terms of showing you
but you know where to go now because
look look there are 3 b squared now
three beasts words so I'm going to say
well that's a squared plus 3 base pay
plus c squared and then you're like well
well what do I do with these guys it's
like well since i'll finish writing
like sorry I can make the same argument
right since I see is less than B C's
lesson be what would you like me to
write next series ii swear who see and
similarly sees not just smaller than B
smears also smaller than hey right
smaller smaller okay so therefore again
I'm going to scream like that is that ok
so these be seized and these acs i'm
going to replace each of them with
something smaller may we see sweaters
right so there 4a squared plus 3 b
squared c squared plus these guys still
less than one and I'm not even going to
write the last line because that's
lastly okay